we're talking about donuts um not these
kind of donuts obviously but um donut
shaped planets that's what we're going
to talk about
can we imagine that you could have a
planet that was shaped literally
like this like a ring you know
physically it is possible yeah the laws
of physics permit you to have a a donut
shape like this
so what what do you need to have such a
configuration basically you need the the
object to be spinning
okay so it needs to be spinning why if
it's not spinning then it's just going
to collapse under under its own gravity
so you need that that centrifugal force
to push outwards if you spin it too much
basically all the material will just
sort of be shot out into space but if
you get it just right in principle
you could get a planet shape like this
it's a very difficult configuration to
sort of engineer
whether it's going to happen naturally
is another matter but maybe some sort of
elong musk type uh alien innovator could
uh you know sort of for whatever reason
it's a big stunt create one
but within laws of physics it is allowed
to have such a configurator you just
need that centrifugal force to push you
out
you could even start with a like an
ellipsoid type type
planet and spin it in the right way and
get the the the doughnut to form again
it would be something
you'd have to do very precisely it
wouldn't just happen you know you knock
it at all and it's going to
destroy it but if you get it right you
can get get something like this to form
and it would actually be roughly stable
in the sense that you know you spin it
up a little bit more it's not going to
destroy it spin it down a little bit
it's not going to destroy it
where it is vulnerable is to things like
tidal forces so this is you know much
more stretched out
than an ordinary planet you know we
think it's orbiting some star
then the difference between sort of the
force here and the force here could
cause it to break up so this is the kind
of instability that it would be
vulnerable to
that actually affects where you might
want to put one of these things
you don't want it to put it too close to
the star
because it will break up for that reason
because of the tidal forces
but of course if you want to live on
this thing you've got to be near enough
to the star to sort of get all the heat
and stuff so actually
if such a thing were to exist you'd
probably want it in the vicinity of a
bright star
uh that way you could be far away but
you know sort of getting enough energy
from from the starters to sort of
support life on it
so it's interesting to think about what
some of the you know features would be
would be like on on this this this crazy
object a lot of it depends on the tilt
so for example if it had zero tilt
relative to the plane of its orbit
the really interesting stuff would
happen on this interior ring
you'd basically get no light on the
interior at all ever
until it would be in a really cold dark
desolate place the water would be frozen
copper ducks would be frozen it would be
quite a horrendous place whereas out
here
it would be perfectly nice and of course
there'd be different you know
temperature differences which could
lead to some extreme weather but but
overall it you know
over here it'd be quite nice over here
it'd be not very nice
the other feature about it is to think
about is the um
you know where what the gravitational
distribution is you would always
sort of fall inwards you know into the
object the gravity would always point
into the object
there's no lateral flow that basically
makes sense because it's a surface of
equal potential it has to be
but where is the gravity least where is
it strongest so if you imagine an object
which was say the mass of the earth and
was spun up to the right rate
what you would find is that this this
region would be a bit flatter than in
this case
the gravity would be weakest here and in
an interior it'd be quite weak here
maybe maybe a third of earth's gravity
and the reason for that is just because
right in here you've got the pull of the
other side pulling you in the wrong
direction
and here you've got the sort of large
centrifugal effects
especially the gravity would be
strongest here still less than earth's
gravity
but the weakest gravitational regions
would be here and here
tony i thought the center of gravity
would be
in the middle there and if you were
living in here you'd be sucked into the
middle
so certainly if you if you're far away
then you that's what you'd experience
right but if you're within the object
you sort of feel the distribution a bit
more and
and indeed the dominant effect of you
around here would be
this mass here okay that's not to say
you don't feel
this region you do and that's why for
example the gravity is weak here
but it but yeah the dominant effect
clearly comes to here and that's how it
holds together it has to be like that
otherwise it wouldn't even hold together
people living on the inside of the ring
aren't being sucked up into space no the
main force would be that way
but they would have competing effects
pulling them that way which is why the
gravity feels weak
what if it was tilted like the earth
like 23 degree tilt you would now get
some light in the interior
okay there would be some light in the
interior particularly on the equator
what you would find is
in the summer in the winter you would
have ordinary days they'd be very short
because this thing's rotating very
quickly it'd probably rotate within a
few hours
okay so you have very short days but but
nevertheless you'd get days and nights
because you would get that cycle of
light
if you were slightly in some sort of
you know region further north or further
south then you would be a bit like the
sort of polar regions here you'd get
like a period of six months without sun
you know and it would be like that
basically very similar to the polar
regions because of that difference
in how much energy these areas received
again you would have quite sharp
temperature differences
maybe some extreme weather um associated
with that
there's also some quite interesting
plate tectonics could occur
as well so you might ask well would you
even have plate tectonics
and naively might say not right because
you know this this has a
very large surface area compared to like
a spherical planet
for example you know compared to its
volume so you might think it's going to
lose a lot of its thermal energy and
therefore you wouldn't have the
volcanism inside
the the uh you know inside this object
but again you've got the tidal forces
which which it feels more of so that
might
that might liven things up a little bit
so this possibility could have
could have some plate tectonics and then
you get some really weird stuff going on
and again the exciting place is this
interior this is where all the fun and
games happens
one thing you'll notice is you take a
region here so imagine a plate
like a tectonic plate has a certain size
here and it fits quite nicely into that
ring there it's that area
but the ring on the outside is much
bigger than the ring on the inside
so if you try to push this plate inwards
it's not got enough space
what's going to happen folding you're
going to get crazy
mountain ranges in here right and you'll
also get rifts as they move away as
as plates try to move out of that region
it's not big enough to fill the space
they go into so you get rift so you get
mounted you get rich you have great
geological structures in here the
grandest of grand canyons
yeah and the other thing to remember of
course is is the gravity is weaker as
well
right so the mounds are going to be
higher so not only do you gonna get
amounts because things get you know
squashing into here but they're going to
be higher as well maybe three times
higher if it's a third of the gravity
yeah there's there's all sorts of crazy
effects that you would get here you'd
get like
very high waves why would highways well
of course once again because of the
weaker gravity so you'll get larger
waves perhaps three times higher you get
high clouds for the same reason
there's quite an exotic region inside
that interior i think compared to
maybe the rest of the planet uh so it's
quite fun
tony we live in this almost infinite
universe that you've talked about with
us before do you think one of these is
formed somewhere
see obviously it's a great question um
one like this with a
with a great hole in the middle well i
mean
is the universe infinite it might even
be donut shaped of course
this is it infinite um if it's infinite
then you might enter the
might be a possibility i think like i
said before it's probably something that
you would have to artificially create
with some fancy technology but what is
interesting and what
could exist and probably does does exist
and our earth may have even been shaped
like this in the past
it's not quite a doughnut like this but
a doughnut with the jam in the middle
this is as i said i was describing it to
my kids and that's what they said they
said
oh it's like a doughnut with the jam in
the middle so what i mean by that is
is you've got this sort of donut
structure on the outside but there's
there's an interior
region as well so the overall shape is
still but don't lie but it's like an
interior region
which is which is there as well like the
jam is essentially which is connected
it's actually got a name it's called a
synestia it's only something that's
apparently so far has appeared in
simulations in particular by
i think it's simon locke and sarah
stewart who are two
physicists working in america what they
showed was they were doing some
simulations of
the early solar system for example and
they showed that when
two objects you know two sort of
planet-sized objects collide
then there's a possibility of forming
one of these these synesthesias
so you have the two planet-sized objects
they come in together
it's extremely generally a lot of heat
so they can essentially vaporize all the
rock
and at the same time they can come in
with a lot of angular momentum
and that angular momentum is going to
combine and it's going to cause them to
spin faster it's just like bringing two
skaters together right you've got two
skaters they're spinning
if they come together then they're going
to combine their own momentum and if
they tuck in they'll spin faster and
faster and faster so you have this
situation where two
planets come in smashing together heat
everything up vaporize everything
and it's spinning like crazy okay what
happens
so in that configuration which is quite
a possible configuration
you find that you get this this rapidly
spinning region in the interior
okay and you might say and it's spinning
like crazy and you say well
well let's look at the gas on the on the
outer edge how fast is that spinning
it's spinning very quickly in fact it's
spinning too quickly in principle
so what you'd say is is it spinning
faster than say a satellite
that would be at the same point so you
know if you take a satellite in orbit
around the planet you can say
you can work out how fast it's spinning
how fast it's it's it's it's going
how fast it's going around orbiting yeah
half-assing orbiting yeah you can work
out
you can work out its speed as a
particular speed based on its altitude
okay and if you bring that that
satellite in towards the edge of the
edge of the planet it'll have a
particular speed that's characteristic
of how high it is
if you compare that speed to the speed
of the
edge bit of gas if the edge bit of gas
is going faster that's a completely
inconsistent configuration you can't
have that it should shoot off
it needs to spread out absolutely
exactly right pretty it needs to spread
out
and that's what happens this is how the
synesthete forms the object that you
create in the impact
is trying to spin too quickly okay so it
needs to spread out its outer gas and it
can do it because
it's all gaseous so it spreads itself
out and it forms this donut shape
so what you have is this inner rotating
core spinning like mud
and you have this gas large gas gauge
you know vaporized objects spread out
okay it looks like a doughnut as i said
it's called a sinestria
uh sin means sort of you know together
the the
the ester part comes from the greek
goddess hestia which is the goddess of
structure so it's like this sort of
together structure you've got the inner
core connected to the
to this outer doughnut like like object
and there's there's good reason to
believe that this our earth
might have had a period of synesthetic
phase
maybe for a few hundred years very early
on oh that shorter time
yeah it's very quick yeah it doesn't say
yeah yeah so it doesn't last very long
and the reason is because the object
cools
so as it cools it starts to shrink okay
so so yeah so it's a temporary phase now
you could in principle have such an
object near a very hot star
it remains vaporized it's spinning then
it could be a synesthete so we could
look for sonestas very close to stars
but there's good reason to believe the
earth did spend some time
as a synesthete and the reason is it can
explain some
quirky features of how the moon was
formed one of the puzzles about the moon
is uh is its content so we know that it
has a lot of its makeup is very similar
to what we see on earth which suggests
they have a common origin
okay and the usual theory is that you
know a mars-sized planet i think it's
called thea
comes crashing into earth and then the
moon sort of spilled it came came from
that
but one of the slightly subtle things
about this is is that
there are elements on earth which are
sort of less abundant
on the moon okay some of the more
volatile stuff stuff like potassium
and sodium it's not it's just not as
common on the moon so why a bit of a
mystery
senescence can explain it and the way
they explain it is
you have this collision semester forms
in the very early earth rates
this is great and then and then inside
the cenestia there's a little bit of the
molten rock
which kind of forms the seed from the
for a proto moon
okay and it sort of gathers around it
and then the sinestro starts to cool now
everything's vaporized at this point
so the more volatile space price and the
less volatile stuff is vaporized
as the senestia cools the less volatile
stuff stuff like silicon
starts to sort of essentially rain down
on the objects so it rains down on the
proto moon it rains down on the central
core
but it's raining silicon on this moon
building the moon up but it's it's
putting the less volatile stuff on there
right the silicons and the
aluminiums and things like that then it
cools so some more the synestia falls in
takes with it all the more volatile
stuff that isn't ready to rain down on
the proto moon yet
leaves the moon behind without any of
that volatile stuff
and everything else cools over time and
falls back into the earth
and explains the the difference so this
is one of the ideas for how the moon was
formed
uh from basically donuts in the in the
early solar system
so the earth that was a donut maybe
can i tell you about a new number so
it's a very scary number it's a bit evil
it's um belfigures prime okay so belfica
one of the seven princes of hell
so black hole will eventually radiate
eventually give off a type of radiation
called hawking radiation right now this
is what you get when you apply
quantum mechanics to the event horizon
of a black hole